bonne humeur mais j'oubliais dallest
schumann né d'un père français et d'une
mère luxembourgeoise devient ministre de
la justice et garde des sceaux sous le
vent je suppose que tu est parfaitement
capable de me répéter tout ce que j'aime
ce gars des hauts
s'il faut et connais mon coup ça mon
cousin gave le zoo d'amnéville youtube
est sûr de nous occuper de tout cas moi
cette musique c'est bon madame celle du
prochaine partant 5 second portugal kiev
au portugal gamme
vingt trois ans que j'attends ça
nombreux fier de chacun de récupérer ses
bagages
moi je bouge mais mon sac unique
26 millions d'euros gros ces individus
pourraient être dangereux sur dix
couleurs tu as trois mots pour
m'expliquer d'où il est argentin
j'espère qu'un jour tu commentes eu des
échos jusqu'à moore témoin qui a battu
pour travailler
le feu de mes entrailles brûle les
poutres de ma raison qui désirent y
goûte on parle éternité et faisons la
chasse aux papillons
je voudrais pas me faire un casse croûte
plutôt pour casse croûte de jeu temps
mais un coup
maintenant tu m'expliques youtube vient
cet argent ou bien je communique camair
des clous dans un film ou quoi
paris 5 euros que j'arrive à roter en
limitant les dégâts gaillard